pop
[Musique]
ce
toujours
[Musique]
mais ces facteurs bicyclette gris
cheveux huile on m'indique les uns
l'huile
ils vont aller autre sens avec pays
cycle est et faut avoir pour une île
quand il faut aller à des penseurs temps
que j'arrive l'huile
il y a autre chose très intéressante
costumes chaussures
à dieppe au jeu jamais entendu parler
seulement depuis ce matin sur plage et
huile est sur mer avec pour coup et
grichka foot mais je sais par le tout
est encore kidal
et généreuse et
j'en attends la peine suprême eux ont
répondu présent maréchal nous voilà du
bon train les sauveurs de
vous le savez on va battre dernier la
cij ne savent pas du tout les filles au
matin avant de justement et là tu ne
sais pas du tout je suis seul ce soir
samedi
bon bref on reprendra pour hélène de
dallaire pendant que je pense mes
enfants je voudrais vous dire quelques
mots sur la cérémonie de dimanche
il ne faut pas confondre le retour de
deux prisonniers avec quelque chose
comme comme la victoire on fait une
petite fête c'est vrai mais c'est parce
qu'on aime beaucoup ce qui rentre
seulement il ne faut pas oublier qu'il y
à une condition à leur retour
c'est la relève la relève ça veut dire
que il ya des français qui partent en
allemagne pour remplacer ceux qui
rentrent
je dis ça surtout pour vos parents pour
que vous le leur répétiez et
particulièrement ceux qui m'ont reproché
de ne pas vous faire chanter la
marseillaise
alors vous leur direz de ma part que la
marseillaise on se la réserve pour une
occasion encore plus joyeuse d'autant
que nos prisonniers depuis huit jours
qui sont entrés ils ont dû l'entendre
pas mal de fois la marseillaise
le premier train de la relève voyez vous
oui
c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous dire et
ce n'est pas parce qu'on découpe des
fleurs en papier bleu blanc rouge que
les allemands sont partis qu'on peut
faire des réflexions quand on les
rencontre ou dire tout ce qu'on a envie
de dire et c'est compris bien les
enfants
alors on continue 1
il voit que tu es gentil du mois en
place une visite voilà enfin reprendre
calmement les paroles du premier couplet
tu colère la nouvelle saillie sont
débarqués ils ont même remarqué c'est
pas possible c'est mais pour nous ça
change rien on continue un point c'est
tout
me dit tu te rends compte de ce que tu
dis ça change rien mais ça change tout
contre 6 ans embarquée mais la marque
hot wheels et je sais tu plaisantes
répare tout de même sur un sujet pareil
je te la mets mon échelle dans la classe
c pour les guirlandes de toute façon pas
un mot de tout ça ni à ma famille aux
gosses pour ce qui est de mes affaires
je préfère qu'ils sachent rien ni les
uns ni les autres
d'accord louis
c'est un type de fécamp kim a franchi
une catastrophe d'après lui mais ce
n'est pas le gros coup il y avait même
des tracts distribués par les anglais
sur lequel il sait être pas bougé
c'était pas l'invasion
j'aime mieux ça m'a coupé les pattes
avec ta façon on sait les choses ça va
changer quelque chose qui a pris une
belle d'enterrement débarquerez
embarqués et des centaines de types sur
le carreau sûrement et ça me fait marrer
crois moi mais ça me coûte ni les bras
et les jambes parce qu'a longtemps j'ai
choisi mon camp et c'est celui où il ya
les anglais de temps alors avec eux ça
peut durer sans transition comme ça et
la seule façon de faire avancer les
choses et toi et moi on les pousse aux
fesses à les feignants vient m'aider à
grande échelle jurons tu veux qu'elle la
connaît pas grosse baisse je comprends
pas madame je la savais on serait pas
dans les vacances de la coopérative fois
hélas ne veut donner encore une chance
on est le 19 tu as ces jours ci dimanche
matin tu la connais pas par coeur tu
joueras pas avec les autres fêtes mais
madame maman me coupe une robe exprès
pour la fête
ben tant pis on la met au jour les
enfants rois
et si au contraire on s'arrête celle des
jeunes et sauf deux garçons qui
voudraient bien nous aider à poser des
guirlandes alors qu'il veut il faudra
aussi une fille beaucoup des lettres sur
la banderole devant la mairie je reviens
de loin si vous m'apprenez la chance en
même temps tout seul je peux pas et bien
moi ma cocotte
si j'ai à coeur mission je vais
apprendre une belle de chanson viens
poupoule viens poupoule vient quand
j'entends les chansons de jeunes sans
doute boily sont bons alors marseillais
jacques vont jouer dans la cour en
attendant les autres si vous voulez
faire un match prenait 4 heures avec les
jeunes et les enfants
moi aussi je viens
même maintenant à quel taux il envieux
c'est pas mauvais qu'est ce que tu fais
là tu as c'est une recette à la mère de
ma femme pourquoi alors là je le saurai
jamais on marque quand je peux le dire
si duval la répartition avec du tube qui
n'a pu en juger les pharmaciens contre
un petit café du beurre tu te rajoute du
miel pur sucre et un peu de calva pour
corser un vers paris par plaisir tu les
as moi tu secoues torride le joue un
petit peu suffisant avec un petit linge
propre et obtient 5 restants du saas et
se voir quand même un drôle de monde
juniors du jeu de nouveaux drames c'est
vachement ils pourront se vanter n'a pas
fait voir du miel et fumé de la star us
sans blague mélanger avec de l'armoise
et pourquoi tu essaies pas la faillite
est noyé or parce que dans mon jardin
est plongée la scarole et puis de leur
moi je retrouve tout le talent des
autres et comme de toute façon je fais
toujours la différence entre du vrai
tabac et n'importe quel autre saloperie
d'arras alors autant on mélange rigole
alors je me sauve et comme tu veux pas
un rempart devant elle londres a demandé
qu'on mette les bouchées doubles alors
fortifications transport de troupes
notation montréal des haricots verts du
note même si sa part idiot tu te
transmets moi je transmets aux gens
riches et aux délais pour les mutations
ça devient difficile de savoir à quelle
unité peut pas prendre une bière qu'on
est amené à renier maintenant ils ont pu
des questions ils ont pu rien de visible
mais ils ont toujours inscrit à l'encré
indélébile leurs numéros d'unités sur
leur calcif sur leurs maillots de corps
commenté je le fais sur le récif gp2
coach ou tu en prends un qui fait faire
sa lessive à l'extérieur taris bonjour
ma part je suis sûr que ça coule bien ce
3e album je le dirai en avance alpha
venir et je vous donnerai pas la recette
parce que je les premiers secrets à 6
degrés si ça vous dérange pas baidu est
en moi je vais faire manger les petits
parce que c'est pas tout les garder mais
faut les nourrir et puis ça encore
qu'ici c'est par le moins dur convient
là bas ici ou en vie le pain a dit en
gros si vous connaissez quelqu'un qui
est intéressé par des bandes de terre
j'ai bien le cas avec des bleus ou
rouges avaient rechapés archinard année
au début journal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous verrez dans nos éditions karam
unique et exceptionnel vient de nous
parvenir aux premières heures de la
matinée les forces d'invasion alliés
conjuguant de très important contingent
dans leur armée de terre de l'air et de
mer ont subi un cuisant échec face au
port de dieppe
quel temps des barbus la bataille été
omis d il est maintenant prêt de 16
heures la tentative de débarquement a
totalement échoué
la radio britannique devait déclarer le
lendemain nos troupes fut reçu par un
véritable rideau le feu
[Musique]
sans cet avion
28 chars d'assaut cinq navires de guerre
dont le berkeley de nombreux transports
de troupes ont été détruits
[Musique]
en anglais on rembarque et laissant plus
de 3500 morts prisonniers ou blessés il
ne fut pas possible aux assaillants de
réduire au silence la défense allemande
et les conséquences de cet échec se
faire sentir pendant toute la durée des
opérations
non
le gouvernement allemand a reconnu la
bravoure téméraires de ces jeunes hommes
que le haut commandement britannique a
sacrifié avec une désinvolture qui a
étonné tous les techniciens militaires
[Musique]
24 heures plus tard ses vues montre
combien la population civile vit preuve
d'un remarquable sang-froid
c'est en reconnaissance de cette
attitude digne et courageuse que le
chancelier hitler a fait libérer tous
les prisonniers de la région de thiès
tentative du 19 août confirme l'opinion
de ceux qui en toute objectivité
considère que depuis hendaye jusqu'à
l'océan glacial des troupes débarquées
ne peuvent ni s'établir isom ap
[Musique]
mes yeux vous venez d'assister à la
projection du document qui sera mon très
bientôt aux populations des territoires
occupés il était d'accord je compléterai
néanmoins par quelques renseignements
qui m'ont été transmis par monfils
lieutenant à la 300 deuxième division
d'infanterie qui a eu l'honneur
d'administrer la raclée aux forces
ennemies
le bilan à 7 heures et de plus de 1250
agresseurs hors de combat dont près d'un
millier de canadiens car vous pensez
bien que le gros josh hill a eu encore
l'habileté de ne pas m'être que de pures
anglais au premier rang chaque jour nous
livrent de nouveaux prisonniers que nous
promenons en chemise dans les rues de la
ville avant de les expédier en allemagne
décidément nous sommes devenus le plus
grand pays touristique du monde tous les
étrangers viennent chez nous tandis que
nous allons chez eux
certaines concentrations d'un navire
sous la côte anglaise confirme le fait
qu'il s'agissait bien d'une tentative
d'invasion ces bâtiments devaient servir
au transport des troupes de renforts
dernière notation messieurs nous n'avons
pu nous engager aucune de nos formations
de réserve pour obtenir ce résultat
messieurs allez là je vous présente un
nouveau venu parmi nous le capitaine
carles et le feld il sera l'adjoint du
commandant vance dorff au bureau de
renseignements
ses états de service m'incite alors
recommander chaudement à votre sympathie
et votre estime sa dernière blessure
l'éloignent de la ligne de feu ici vous
l'aiderez à supporter notre tranquillité
cette fois messieurs
capitaine el feld je suis très très
heureux merci valter pour avoir si vite
apporté ce film c'était bien facile nous
l'avions en contrôle de censure et
saint-germain-en-laye n'est pas si loin
de paris si tu viens d'un soir je
t'attends de pied ferme à l'hôtel
lutetia revers en main vous de même
capitaine il ya peu de chances que
j'accompagne mon chef de service
s'il part je le remplace mais je ne dis
pas non pour l'invitation sol vous ne
leur restait pas longtemps
valter est un grand connaisseur pour les
cinq choses les plus importantes de la
vie le cognac le cigare les dames la
peinture italienne est un petit peu
aussi l'interrogatoire des suspects et
disons accessoirement la récolte des
renseignements les très hautes
responsabilités qui incombent à ma
charge ne m'empêche de rester avec vous
croyez que je le regrette bien capitaine
les traditions valter tu as 2 semaines
pour tenir parole
à moins que la paix à l'ouest soit signé
d'ici là c'est un engagement que je
limite à la durée de la guerre
vous avez toujours l'air aussi soucieux
aussi sévère je ne suis pas encore très
à l'aise comme honda
je ne connais personne ici j'attends des
nouvelles de ma famille
ce film a donné l'impression que le
reich avait gagné la guerre sans moi je
ne crois pas que vous me dites
exactement ce que vous pensez et que je
devine
oui oui je suis très bon observateur
vous est ulcérée par votre mutation de
la très glorieuse armée d'afrique au peu
glorieux service enseignement de la
paire et vous n'avez confiance néanmoins
ni en personne de ceux qui nous
entourent ici et que vous considérez
comme des planqués
vous ne croyez absolument pas qu'il
s'agissait de l'invasion
ah vous voyez j'ai touché juste moi non
plus je ne sais pas convaincu mais alors
il faut le dire oh voilà bien longtemps
que j'ai relancé la parole je suis une
paire d'oreilles une paire de prunelles
je vois j'écoute
j'essaie de comprendre et je fais des
notes mais enfin commandant si personne
ne parle
le pire peut arriver nous avons tous
croire que l'ennemi est définitivement
vaincu or ce n'est qu'un raid un coup de
main plus important que les autres me
absolument pas le débarquement
nous n'avons pas le droit de les
imaginer un seul instant pas le droit de
nous rassurer à si bon compte
voyons quels effectifs en qui l'engagé
il ya deux ans alors que nous devions
nous envahir l'angleterre
je suivais les cours spéciaux des unités
de chars dans les îles de la frise je me
rappelle parfaitement il mansart mais
que nous formions la force terrible que
nous représentions et nous nous avons
renoncé malgré une aviation formidable
un froid encore unique alors leurs 6 8
et 10 mille hommes et quelques dizaines
de chars non
est-ce qu'on peut participer mais bien
sûr je disais à notre nouveau camarade
et il est parfaitement d'accord avec moi
sur ce point qu'il défend d'ailleurs
avec une chaleur bien sympathique
je lui disais donc mon inquiétude de
voir certains d'entre nous et surtout
des biens plus hauts personnages
s'aveugler sur la valeur réelle de notre
succès c'est une victoire aux
conséquences incalculables
le tournant de la guerre nous savons
désormais que nous pouvons sans craindre
porter tous nos efforts sur le front de
l'est ainsi capitale pour la conduite
des opérations
voilà exactement là exactement ce qu'il
est dangereux d'admettre sans examen
plus poussé capitaine schulter un tel
optimisme s'ils étaient partagés en haut
lieu pourrait conduire au dégagement du
front de l'ouest et qui vous dit que ce
n'est pas là le but recherché par la
nuit dégarnir cette ligne que notre
fureur ne l'oublié pas voeux est
infranchissable depuis l'extrême nord de
la finlande jusqu'aux pyrénées
pourraient constituer un danger mortel
pour l'europe
certes je vous accorde immense victoire
bien
néanmoins et ceci concerne tous les
officiers de mon service j'exige que
dans l'accomplissement de nos tâches
quotidiennes nous comportions comme s'il
ne s'était agi devant dieccte que d'une
opération a un objectif très limité
c'est à dire c'est à dire que plus que
jamais nous attendons le département
sans aucunement relâcher notre attention
c'est au maréchal von rundstedt qu'il
appartient encore et jusqu'à nouvel
ordre de décider au dessus de nous de la
situation à l'ouest
nous sommes ses informateurs l'organe de
centralisation de tout ce qui va lui
permettre de l'apprécier à sa juste
valeur
notre mission consiste donc à percer le
secret des dieux qui sont en face les
dieux mais oui c'est une expression et
les dieux ne sont pas toujours bons
choletais père c'est donc leur secret
prévoir leurs agissements déjouer leur
ruse est en réalité répondre à deux
toutes petites questions
où et quand viendront-ils car si nous
avons la juste réponse sur ces deux
points précis alors oui oui qu'à vienne
vite le jour de l'affrontement entre
plus grand ennemi notre plus grand
ennemi capitaine ce n'est ni l'amérique
ni la russie ni l'angleterre ni même de
france
notre plus grand ennemi c
c'est l'euphorie aveugle à dans le clip
leur arrive au palais des sports de
berlin
[Applaudissements]
dans son discours qui devait avoir un
énorme retentissement dans le monde
le führer après avoir souligné l'immense
porte et de la lutte contre les soviets
a annoncé que l'armée allemande venait
d'engager des opérations d'une envergure
gigantesque préparant des événements
décisifs
j'espérais quand même une meilleure des
forces de la part d'officiels et sté
générale à mon sens nous avons agi avec
trop de vente
après la réussite de saint nazaire non
sans prix il fallait lever le doigt et
dire désolé messieurs mais c'est ton
tour
or vous ne l'avez pas fait et vous ni
vos subordonnés
j'assume toute la responsabilité
générale est le résultats que vous avez
obtenus n'autorise pas le commandement
vous en confier d'autres dans l'immédiat
sinon celle ci le capitaine de vaisseau
donald du pavage sera chargé à effet du
1er mardi suivant la réception de cet
ordre
nous sommes samedi vous avez donc trois
jours de prendre la sous direction de
l'unité industrielle d'équipements
militaires ces 28 b x 3 la
sous-direction vraiment quelqu'un de
compétent à la direction
mismari callaghan des forces féminines
de l'armée de l'air et c'est unité
industrielle fabrique des ballons
d'observation saucisses saucisses
elles seront très utiles le jour venu
surtout si vous n'essayez pas d'en
améliorer la fabrication je sais
parfaitement qu'il est très incorrect
d'intervenir général mais je suis
solidaire du commodore op vol merci
williams très touché j'ajoute que nous
avons alerté l'amirauté sur le manque de
discrétion n'est pas par hâtif
nous n'avons pas obtenu les bombardiers
indispensable mais si nous voulons
interpréter les résultats l'opération
jubilé se solde par la perte de 32
navires 106 avions 28 chars de combat
806 morts 5 158 blessés
1536 prisonniers ou disparus sur un
effectif de 6000 hommes
quel que soit votre interprétation nous
avons perdu le match
monsieur tous les états majors sont
consternés cette affaire de diem est un
lamentable échec et j'ai tendance à
croire que cela tient en partie à ce
qu'elle a été préparée par une équipe
lamentable jeu
dresser en verre est bien assez merci
donald
j'espère que ça n'a pas été trop cruel
ce matin la fin était inélégante cette
répétition du mot lamentable le puits
l'affectation baudruche il fallait que
votre disgrâce soit évidente pour vos
jeunes gens et j'espère pour tous ceux
auxquels ils raconteront la seule vous
êtes un type fini je le pense aussi
le malheur c'est la nouvelle atteindra 7
dans les oreilles de ma soeur je vis
avec elle non plus maintenant et saufs
épisodiquement comme suit votre mutation
à la fabrique de saucisses d'observation
était bien réel
oui mais le moins possible à londres
disons nous le fois par semaine j'ai
trouvé un endroit pour vous et vos
adjoints un manoir et s'est isolé
votre mission est ingrate et complexe je
crois que le temps est venu de vous
informer plus précisément sur ce que
nous attendons de vous voyez vous donald
nous connaîtrons probablement jamais
l'exacte vérité sur les raisons qui ont
précipité cette malheureuse affaire de
diack ni vous ni moi ne sommes assis sur
les genoux de jupiter à mon sens
l'opération avait pour but inavoué de
prouver à l'oncle staline qui n'est pas
si simple d'ouvrir un second front à
l'ouest net je ne reviendrai pas sur ma
bible certains pensent qu'il fallait
aussi calmé l'ardeur du contingent
canadien s'est fait et pour longtemps
en l'évoquant encore d'autres raisons
qu'importe le connaître la bonne la
seule certitude est que nous avons été
rejetés à la mer et que nous avons subi
de très lourds de pertes
l'ennemi lui est pratiquement indemne
la prochaine fois sera différente
la prochaine fois ne serait ce qu'à
cause des effectifs engagés sera
probablement aussi la dernière fois
quelle que soit l'issue
je me sers machinalement comme si
j'étais au club lui qui parle à toujours
plus soif que celui qui écoute
savez vous demande ce qu'il faut de
navires pour le débarquement d'une seule
division blindée 45 cargo et transport
on nous engagerons des dizaines de ses
divisions
les centaines de navires des milliers
d'avions et de planeur et aussi des
centaines et des centaines de milliers
d'hommes qu'il faudra nourrir soigner
évacuer alimenté en véhicule et en
essence et faire suivre aussi de
centaines et de centaines de milliers
d'autres aux hommes qui auront attendu
leur tour ici dans notre sacré via il
comme sur un quai de gare et tout
commencera un certain jour alain certain
nombre
vous êtes un homme intelligent donald
mais tout de même temps au point d'avoir
obtenu si facilement dans ton diplôme de
la marine avec une formation des
thématiques aussi discutable que la
vôtre je suis encore capable de faire
mieux que vous dans votre propre
spécialité
alors comment avez vous fait eh bien je
vais vous dire vous êtes une personne
intelligente mais surtout très rusé très
maligne au point j'en suis sûr d'avoir
fait croire à vos examinateurs que vous
enviez plus longues heures c'est sur
cette appréciation personnelle que je
vous ai chaleureusement recommandé alors
mountbatten pour prendre la direction du
bureau zelda vous ne dépendrait que de
moi même personne ne citera jamais votre
section dans l'histoire de cette guerre
et il se peut même que personne n'en
relèvent jamais d'existence z est une
lettre trop éloignés dans l'ordre
alphabétique
c'est très léger très alléchant pour
quelqu'un qui rêvait de commander la
flotte de sa majesté il y ait 20 ans et
cela consisterait au début vous n'aurez
pas grand chose à faire
je veux dire physiquement et en fait
s'il n'y a pas de problème que vous
l'aurez peut-être absolument rien à
faire du tout et est le genre de
problème
n'importe quel genre de problèmes posés
par l'organisation du débarquement sur
le continent et seulement si personne
n'a pu le résoudre avant évidemment
signée annie bénissez
nielly f ni les ingénieurs ni les
toubibs ni les astrologues il est ni les
radiesthésistes n'ont trouvé oui ce sera
pas au bout
j'avais pourtant bien préparé mon cou
podium
nous le savons tous donald minceur ne le
saura jamais ce sera seulement que nous
avons éprouvé un cuisant revers mais ça
aussi nous le savons on me fait pas
sortir de mes gonds je vous ai parlé du
principal problème celui que de toute
manière nous ne pourrons éviter de voir
se poser et qui à lui seul vous occupera
beaucoup le secret la préservation du
secret quels secrets
le secret de la date et du lieu du
débarquement à l'ouest la plus grande
opération combinée de tous les temps ce
n'est pas raisonnable robert n'avait pas
demandé un capitaine de vaisseau en
disgrâce imméritée d'assurer le
camouflage de dizaines de milliers de
véhicules de bateaux d'avions près
retard heures l'ennemi tout courant des
mouvements de nos troupes par ses avions
de reconnaissance les abattons plus
rapidement qu'ils ne les remplace
l'agencé espions leur enseigne vous
aideront à les prendre et à lire tomé
enfin robert le bruit que feront nos
troupes en enfilant leurs chaussures
toutes ensemble au matin du débarquement
s'entendra jusqu'à berlin
elles devront enfiler cent fois leurs
chaussures pour rien avant et berlin ne
croira jamais que la 101e et là bas et
si le grand et bien justement vous avez
un truc pour qu ils croient aussi
connaître l'heure à laquelle nous
frapperons et l'endroit mais seront ni
la bonne heure ni le bon endroit et si
vous êtes aussi malin que j'ai eu
peut-être le tort de l'affirmer en haut
lieu
même si la nuit comprend que c'est un
truc et devra penser que votre vouliez
l'amener à ça à comprendre que c'est
un truc et il agira comme si ça ne
l'était pas a par méfiance
voilà voilà ce que nous attend dans le
moule donald bouvet encore refuser le
commodore yann feeling a refusé marouane
stoll a refusé
moi j'ai refusé mais nous serons
vraiment très nombreux sur cette liste
de refus robert pourquoi on essayait
vous pas du côté du lieu de charité enc
il n'a pas vraiment dit nom n'est pas
encore dit oui je demande quelques
instants de réflexion alors que je serai
devant lord mountbatten je sais que je
ne pourrai plus revenir en arrière
ce débarquement c'est comme si on devait
préparer un hold up
exactement c'est aussi simple que ça et
personnellement je marchais avec vous
les yeux fermés pour le raisonnement
cette fois dites vous que les flics se
doute de quelque chose qu'ils montent la
garde devant la porte du coffre puis et
à trop de conflits ce projet en courant
dans cette affaire pour que je puisse
garantir qu'il n'y aura ni moucharder
les fuites d'aucune sorte
nous avons aussi de sérieux atouts de
notre côté beaucoup d'amis dans la place
je sais comment vous décidez donald au
bureau comme talent
je vais vous montrer quelque chose
d'intéressant et si je retiens votre
image du hold up
je crois que j'ai déjà le plan de la
banque
mais ce sont des non français
et bien entendu c'est la côte française
d'un dieccte à cherbourg
ce document est ultra secret au nahd
tout y est répertorié casemate blockhaus
les plateformes de mitrailleuses la
circulation entre tous ces dispositifs
les poules munitions le nombre des
tâches prévues
ce sera mon premier cadeau à ma
protection comme services spéciaux
s'efforce sans relâche de subtiliser
l'ennemi ce type de document pour nous
ne savons même pas où il se fabrique
quelque part lambert là je suppose dans
les sous sols de quelques ministères on
peut penser qu'il existe le même pour
chacun des secteurs du fond d'invasion
possible de la côte basque au cap nord
une faille est un miracle pour que ce
plan tombe entre nos mains est aussi un
sacré culot comme disent les français
et bien c'est comme ça que c'est arrivé
il ya quelques mois grâce au sacré culot
d'un responsable la résistance en
normandie
la méthode de cet homme est d'une
extrême habilité ils ne dissimulent
absolument pas ses sentiments hostiles à
l'occupant au contraire il les étalent
au grand jour avec ostentation
la police allemande depuis longtemps
repérée et étiquetés bavard et
inoffensif
non sans blague hein ça moi si je le
rencontre a en personne je dirais
carrément sous la moustache collègue
jean riant un peu monsieur raoul weil
ont un jour je suis là il va comprendre
ben alors son patron de la boîte est
peintre en bâtiment comme moi ça rien
d'insultant and german
ben voyons non moi je dirais je dirais
collègues je serai que toi je ferai des
comptes parce que au nord d'ottawa
famélique et le recul 300 km au 102 100
comme ça tient mieux parce qu'au sud
c'est encore du 300 morts dans l'ariège
et pourquoi le froid le froid le général
hiver bon c'est terminé mais attention
le prochain c'est qu'avant c'est pas
comme s'il nous voulons mais comptons
juin juillet août septembre quatre mois
quatre mois et s'est longtemps la pluie
la bouillasse et là dessus re l'hiver
c'est là que je les attendre quatre mois
pour se refaire une santé pour organiser
et prévoir prévoir c'est que rien n'est
prévu tout est affaire production
industrielle de braseros un bail quad
deux sacs de carvi par jour tiens les
boissons chaudes 10 heures à 12 heures
16 heures et à partir de 18h brûlante
c'est là leur talent ailleurs la
photographe avant tout le monde rame
german voix est encore un petit monsieur
herman les blagueurs mais j'en étais
gosse gros trou qui lui très bavard il
en faut des comme ça amusant et a amusé
en la ramenant les guerres tristement
pas bon ça ça bah oui bon ça
qu'est ce que tu racontes tt cas de
tetris et ely mais qu'est ce que tu me
dis que c'est lié aux d'ailleurs les
sports nautiques ans il commençait ne
pas courir la fiche d'appel d'offres
invitant les entreprises de peinture à
soumissionner qui pressent là le moyen
de pénétrer dans cette place un troll à
la direction
l'organisation de leurs grilles de noël
combien aujourd'hui sur les mers aux
bénévoles y suit la voie la même manière
de remercier
un grand pas
[Musique]
d'accord
que dire
m
non sire cavale at-on dit
vous
il ya mes jeux
[Musique]
alors monsieur ont fait du bruit
non monsieur l'officier balla et à
huntsman
oui alors monsieur leubou leiter pas b
comme comme bêtes brutes bruit qu'un
beau leiter il ya mes mémoires français
moi entrepreneurs peinture raul souchez
ouais moi français mais vive pétain
vivent leurs émois pape tine quand
monsieur souchez expliquez-vous
intelligiblement bravo bon voilà je sais
que vous cherchez des entreprises de
peinture pour des travaux j'ai vu une
affiche ou des pères non mais je sais
pour les soumissions ça s'arrêtait ici
on health est là dessus j'ai rien à dire
c'est correct mais où ça va pas c'est
quand on nous refuse de m'expliquer
parce que votre sentinelle service
service ordre discipline marc et moi
j'ai rien moi je rêvais plutôt pour mais
faut pas sectaire on se comprend pas lui
et moi d'ailleurs pas bon mais je sais
bien quand il ment gueule alors mettez
vous à ma place
vaincus c'est déjà pénible mais bousculé
non
ça rendu d'ailleurs voilà j'aime un
moment qui est malade
attendez alors je vais la voir tous les
jours je vais la voir depuis bastia
depuis votre victoire de benghazi 23
janvier et le 21 janvier louis 16 23
janvier à benghazi et donc qu'a coûté le
relais vous voulez vous en venir le
monsieur s'il vous plaît vous me
fatiguez avec toutes ces paroles là où
je veux en venir
je veux mon droit et la justice une mère
malade 50 ans malheur je soumissionnent
pour les travaux trop tard mais il n'y a
pas de vraie et seule travaux qui
restent ont poussé les anciens de mon
propre bureau et les deux pièces au foie
si ça marche
voyons monsieur pas ça s'appelle à la
concurrence à la concurrence d'un
concurrent à lacets missionné un
concurrent à la bourre moi j'en ai pas
je vous fais 10 % de rabais sur le moins
disant
il ya ce policier 15 % de rabais
je peux demander une minute le direction
technique services program et
approvisionnement à toutes les
entreprises faillies de terrassement
travaux publics maçonnerie béton armé à
dater de ce jour il sera tenu pour toute
entreprise année une comptabilité
matière concerne les africa
le droit de chômage riz les asian des
lancements des satellites et quotidienne
sera comme idrissa un bond de
l'organisation dont et chaque soir elle
sera tenue entre le cci de caen 7 mai
1902 direction technique comprendra et
approvisionnement à toutes les
entreprises agréées terrassement travaux
publics
[Musique]
et si vous mettez quotidiennement une
comptabilité matière quotidienne at-il
tout ça c'est de contaminer comédienne
j'aurai la veille cette comptabilité
sera remise aux responsables allemands
et chaque parole chaque soir sur les
chantiers par la responsable est signée
de l'entreprise française qu'il haïra
conz à présent pour un client brian
snyder
vous êtes encore là
ah oui j'adore votre réponse caisse pour
sandra mais 15% de frapper il faut ça
fait de jolis paquets j'en ai même vu
date leur a guère apporté les
échantillons des coûts possibles donnant
ça je vous le dis demain matin un
première heure suis là et puis au tibet
au revoir monsieur le golan le bao bao
la terre qui vous voulez boucher le jeu
je suis votre homme descend à la pioche
pour des touristes question de
sang-froid culot les 5
les 5es pas de chance
fondée à pied de leur côté assurent top
set nadal commence à un pied les deux
pieds où ils rient demain avec les deux
yeux et mon pif de bonnes blagues alors
aa 4 et 5 9 10 17 25 j'ai perdu la
revanche l'autre jour j'ai pas bien la
femme de faire la queue à la boucherie
je crois que j'applique un gros machin
secret qu'elle machin pour le budget
plus en voix par transparence et à
l'envers c'est le plan des
fortifications sur la croûte may encore
chez de jeu sortirait demain alors à
demain allemagne
je ne sais pas sur quel pied danser avec
lui et s'il bluffe est-ce qu'il se fout
de nous est ce que on verra bien alors
j'arrive à la porte avec mes roues lot
d'échantillons je frappe
je voulais en farine et c'était plus
belles prises et du jour au lendemain
ils m'ont changé mon beau lac berté
wajda
sur le coup j'ai cru qu'ils avaient
découvert le pot-aux-roses je comprenais
rien pour qu ils m'ont violée nous et le
pire c'est que les blancs ou nuls
il est choquant à cacher ce salon bien
tant mieux comme ça le jeu ne valait
sûrement pas la chandelle
s'ils ne se sont aperçus de rien c'est
eux probablement votre plan ne valait
pas grand chose ajoute juste pour avoir
tech
il suffirait l'instant qu'une femme de
ménage à peu frileuse l'automne vaduz
elle est d'avis que j'ai trouvé vous
devinerez jamais ou du coup ma petite
visite pourra leur année en mémoire en
vie dont star est allé pour des
broutilles pas le bon c'est bien simple
si je pouvais j'aimerais le remettre
dans sa boîte mon plan miracle et que ce
serait donc fini la belle devise sang
froid et culot c'est pas encore la
grande panique
mais comme une mollesse dans les
abdominaux
vite on suivra no
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors il faut employer l'armée allemande
pas votre recherche monsieur souche et
la conscience n'est pas tranquille
n'est ce pas je suis rentré de mon
inspection à saint malo et qu'est ce que
je découvre que vous n'avez rien fait
encore cette semaine les français
promettent toujours la pop
vous avez engagé quelque chose monsieur
souche et il faut retenir le moins de 10
ans avec 15 % de rabais
on ne le revoit plus sérieux même si
c'est ça mais je suis venu je suis venu
et revu mais sait on m'a foutu à la
porte avec mes bros mais rouleau mais
mes peintures et tout moi moi j'étais
pas à m'y mettre et maintenant vous êtes
encore pris je repars pour 48 heures à
mon retour j'ai peur que cette pièce ici
soit éliminé
ça y est je laisse vous avez quoi mont
blanc est simplement plus fantastique
que tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer et
ont du charme tout le fameux mur de
l'atlantique entre cherbourg et honfleur
ce qu'ils ont fait et ce qu'ils vont
faire le cospar blockhaus pièces
d'artillerie par les intérêts elle croit
pas et je vous dis que j'ai jeté un coup
d'oeil dessus je le jure et où peut-on
passer le prouve ce super documents
secrets vous savez que les allemands
intensifie les raf et les descentes de
police à l'improviste
bah là où je n'ai mis en risque pas
grand chose terral vous pouvez le
package oublié sur votre serviette
merci
ce document est arrivé à londres deux
mois plus tard je vous le confirme un
bien très précieux
donald
je crois que la visite alors mombaerts
nathalie lambert mais j'accepte à deux
conditions
la première j'agirai entièrement ma
guise mais naturellement vous aurez à
laissez passer spécial l'accès à toutes
les archives à tous les documents tous
les travaux préparatoires à toutes les
conférences et vous aurez même un
téléphone trafic et pour éviter toute
écoutes clandestines
vous allez vieillir d'un mois par
semaine au début j'ai ça ne pourra que
s'aggraver
jusqu'au jour où des millions d'hommes
devront leur salut ou leurs pertes au
fait que vous aurez réussi ou échoué
dans votre travail deuxième division
le choisir et moi même mon équipe
naturellement le meilleur dans chaque
discipline sauf peut être l'adjoint
direct
j'ai mon idée sur votre adjoint direct
ce sera une bonne surprise pour vous je
crois mais il faut y aller immédiatement
vous avez fait les annales c'était tel
bras sûr de votre acceptation que je lui
ai fait téléphoner de votre part et il
se peut qu ils vous attendent déjà
[Musique]
après vous aime cela voici votre adjoint
donald avouer que nous vous avons bien
eu ce matin vous et les autres à revenir
à je ne pensais pas qu'il s'agissait
d'une comédie comme alors considéré
qu'il n'aurait plus jamais confiance en
vous et bien voilà c'est parfait aucune
confiance
vous allez faire une équipe magnifique d
aller au real j'ai particulièrement
apprécié votre soutien dans une
circonstance je préférerais que nous
reprenions désormais les distances
réglementaires
je comprends le coût et met parfaitement
irrégulière vers notre temps du tout
vous allez essayer de vous épater de
vous vous surpassez de vous écraser l'un
l'autre excellente stimulation
intellectuelle
je termine mon verre et je vous laisse
en tête à tête de ces que vous l'aimez
sept capitaines tous fait des pas si
grave et l'homme mattenet bas des
subordonnés qui se font grise mine
il a bien trop d'humour pour ça
voyez-vous lors de la dernière
conférence après votre malheureux fiasco
de dieppe quelqu'un résumait la
situation à 10 ans nous avons échoué
parce que nous avons attaqué un port de
chaque port les allemands ont fait une
forteresse imprenable
il faut donc débarquer ailleurs ce
serait plus sûr plus facile
malheureusement apport est indispensable
au succès de l'entreprise
cédric insoluble et lord mountbatten
adding saufs
si nous amenons notre port avec nous je
crois que c'est le premier problème sur
lequel vous pourriez réfléchir tous les
deux
[Musique]
oh